so who is my guest this week the grand
slam tennis champion andy murray
the career span of an elite athlete can
be short but this british tennis player
has already packed a hell of a lot into
his 35 years
three grand slam wins and a former world
number one he's battled injury to remain
on the court bagging tens of millions of
dollars along the way
but for the greatest uk player since
virginia wade it's always been about
more than the money he's turned down
endorsements and done things his own way
from his early years when some of the
public were unsure of him he's now
ranked by pollsters as the most popular
tennis player in the world
as he faces what could be his last
wimbledon what does he do next and can
he avoid the pitfalls that occur for so
many top sports players once they've
quit their game
[Music]
this is what's coming up i know we're
talking ahead of wimbledon of course do
you have to go in believing you can win
again
yeah i mean i think that's part of the
the motivation to still be out there
competing i know it's going to be
even harder to win
wimbledon than it was five six years ago
but yeah i i still believe and
i'm still working and training as hard
as i can to try and try and achieve that
goal you've been very influenced by
strong women in your life not least your
mum the pro tennis coach of course judy
murray and she recently wrote an article
about being sexually assaulted at an
awards dinner by a man sat next to her i
was obviously really upset for her i was
pretty angry but also didn't
i didn't know quite exactly what to say
um it's a familiar story for for a lot
of women and
yeah that that sort of behavior
shouldn't shouldn't be tolerated
anywhere
andy murray hello thank you very much
for talking to me hi how are you doing
do people call you sir andy ever
um rarely no i try to avoid that when i
can no i mean you you are a knight so i
just was remembering do your kids ever
call you it uh i don't think they're
aware of it they do they have started
calling me andy murray
which i find
pretty awkward you know they tend to
when um when they're around their other
friends um to wind me up so well it
sounds like you've taught them well to
wind you up already i love that andy
murray from your children i i know we're
talking ahead of wimbledon of course do
you have to go in believing you can win
again yeah i mean i think that's part of
the the motivation to still be out there
competing i know obviously that's going
to be
unbelievably difficult thing to do but
um
you know i do still believe that i've
got great tennis in me um i know it's
gonna be
even harder to win
wimbledon than it was five six years ago
um
but yeah i i still believe and um i'm
still working and training as hard as i
can to try and try and achieve that goal
yes well i mean we should say case
people don't know you you've had a lot
of pain
injuries particularly around your hip
and you know i read that you're inspired
by the likes of muhammad ali and sports
stars who make big comebacks
is that part of the psychology for me i
came back to play tennis because i love
it that's why um i came back to play um
it's been
something i've done since i was a really
young kid and you know pretty much since
my sort of teenage years it's been the
main thing in my my life and i've
dedicated a lot of time to it and i kind
of realized when i was going through all
of the injuries and pain and wasn't able
to compete like how much i did love it
and um
yeah probably wish at times certainly
earlier in my career that i
appreciated it a bit more and enjoyed it
a little bit more than i did yes
i mean i am fascinated by how
individuals do cope with pain i actually
live with a condition
called endometriosis so i'm i'm quite
regularly in pain of course everyone's
pain is very subjective to them and in
your case it stopped you at many moments
from doing what you wanted what you what
you dream of what you train of how have
you coped with pain well
i think as as athletes you're used to
sort of always having a certain level of
pain from
you know the training and the matches
that you do you know and that's kind of
normal so i think you
most athletes probably have a relatively
high sort of pain tolerance but then
went with my hip um and i dealt with
discomfort in my hip for probably six or
seven years until it basically
from one day to the next went from you
know i was
ranked number one in the world at the
time to
i literally can't walk properly anymore
and you know i couldn't extend my hip
and was in constant pain every time you
know even when i went to walk the dogs
and i think
initially
that's obviously difficult to deal with
but i think over time it's the
consistency of the pain and it just
being every single day that sort of
sort of wore me down and
i filmed a documentary during my sort of
rehab and all the injuries and the
surgeries and stuff yes and when i
watched that back i kind of
realized
which i didn't whilst i was going
through it like i was in a pretty bad
place so i probably didn't deal with it
particularly well um
you know in the end but it had been
going on for a long time and it was
stopping me
you know from doing what what i love as
well and i cannot wait to see you back
at wimbledon i really really can't i i
did i did think about though when you
were in that state and i know about that
film i've watched that film that you
made
i was thinking about whether you got to
a place but maybe it's premature to ask
you this but have you have you thought
about
how you will be happy or satisfied if
you never win another grand slam yeah i
mean like i
i i don't expect um that to happen i
still believe that i can do it but
um
you know i i got to a point um before i
had the operation that i had to
contemplate not playing tennis again and
i was fighting and battling with that as
well during the
the injury troubles and you know i knew
that when i had the hip resurfacing that
there was a chance i might not be able
to play again and i had to come to terms
with that once i did um
you know i i feel fine i know that
i'll be fine if i had to stop playing
tennis tomorrow you know
i'll be absolutely fine i've got a great
family i would obviously miss playing
tennis um but i have lots to look
forward to you know away from
away from the tennis court
you're a fashion designer now right
you've you've just been doing a photo
shoot i believe a model and a fashion
designer your sportswear
andy murray let me get this right andy
murray castor you know that's your your
new calling right yeah so
i mean i i wouldn't call myself a
fashion designer um
i don't know a whole lot about fashion
um to to be honest but you know i try
and get involved as much as i can in
terms of the
the way the
the clothes perform on on the tennis
court that's something that interests me
a lot um
so i try and help with that i test a lot
of the kit and everything before i
obviously have to perform on it and give
feedback and try to make improvements um
to where i can but yeah i let the
fashion designers take care of the
fashion side of things because uh i'm
i don't know a whole lot about that we
can underestimate the power of clothes
and for you i suppose it's it's it's
something you wrap yourself in it's a
bit of an armor at the same time
yeah i mean it's it's really important
for us and you know the shoes as well um
you know
it it can't make a difference to to your
performance and certainly like the
clothes and you know extreme conditions
like we play in
australia where it's you know
40 degrees and in
like places like miami where it can be
you know
85 90 humidity so you need to make sure
that you know the materials and stuff
that you're wearing um
you know are appropriate for for the
conditions
um so yeah it is is important i just
have to say i talked about watching you
of course as a brit i feel i've lived
many moments with you you know on my
knees standing up hiding behind the sofa
willing you on to win but one of the
things that i wanted to ask you was
about your kind of fist pump that you do
and that roar that you do to the crowd
what what's going on there what are you
thinking about when people like me are
watching you do that point after point
after point yeah i mean i think it's
just well a little bit is obviously
trying to encourage yourself um
but then yeah there's moments in a match
where
you're trying to engage with the crowd
um that are coming there to to watch the
tennis hopefully be entertained but to
support one of the two players out there
and when people come to
to watch sporting events they want to
see that that emotion um
you know
hopefully you know it's positive emotion
but sometimes you know for me it's uh
you know it's negative um as well um
you know i wish i was able to control
the negative emotions that i have you
know when i'm playing better but i feel
like when i do it you know to the crown
fist pump and you know get excited on
the court that you know i'm trying to
engage the crowd no no and it's great to
of course have crowds back and feed off
that energy do you what do you make of
groaning and grunting whilst playing do
you what do you make of that some
spectators find that not the best but i
wonder how it is as a as a player and
other spectators love it i remember
growing up watching monica sellers for
instance
there's a certain level that i think is
okay and almost like natural when you're
putting lots of effort into something
but
when it's at a level that is
sounds and seems unnatural then that's
when
this may be a little bit off-putting and
then some players are maybe doing it
like so long that the ball's
already getting hit by the opponent
you know whilst they're grunting and
that you know is is not not good because
you know
this should should be a hindrance really
yes it's not their ball very much at
that moment no i can i can only imagine
what we're just speaking about of course
again uh with regards to wimbledon ahead
of it um you will be very aware of the
the controversy going into this
wimbledon surrounding the decision to
ban russian and belarusian uh players
you've acknowledged how complicated this
decision is you chose your words very
carefully and you have sympathy for the
players who can't play and the
authorities who have done this it's a
really difficult one this isn't it well
my sympathy is first and foremost are
worth in ukraine
and what they're going through and
um you know in the grand scheme of
things like whether some tennis players
are not able to play in an event or not
and whether there's you know ranking
points on offer in the grand scheme of
things is kind of irrelevant you know
obviously know quite a few of the
russian players and i'm friends with
them and i i feel for them that they're
not able to compete i can appreciate
that it may seem unfair to them but i
can also see you know wimbledon's side
and their point of view and the
perspective that they have and it's it's
very complex but at the end of it
you know there's a war going on you know
that's you know what people should be
focusing on and
you know we want that to end as as
quickly as possible and
you know a tennis tournament
isn't really that important i don't
think no i i think that's obviously the
the concepts and a very important one to
to do and i know you're an ambassador
for unicef i know you're also donating
uh the proceeds of any of your
payments or winnings this year to the
effort to support children in particular
in ukraine but i think what's very
striking about you andy is is you have
been outspoken about a number of issues
over the years you know uh before almost
not that it was fashionable but the you
know people in sport perhaps taking
positions uh whether it's about the
mental health of of young players to
sexism in sport as well as something i
know you care deeply about
do you get more confident to share
opinions as you get older or less does
it does it become easier or harder
i think in some ways it becomes easier
because you're maybe
i don't know when you're in your early
20s you don't really know much about
anything really and i'm not saying i
know lords now but i know a lot more now
than i i did then and maybe you know
trust my my views a little bit better
than i did then and
you know i also
feel as well like since since i had
children that i want to make sure that
you know
i support things that are important to
me and that hopefully will will maybe
you know help the world that my children
grew up in um
as well so
in some ways yes it does maybe does help
as you get older maybe it becomes a bit
easier to share your opinions but at the
same time
um you know with everything that goes on
online
nowadays and everything like you know
online abuse and
you know those sorts of things
at times you think well what's the point
i'll just say nothing because
you know it's an easier life that way as
well and you know i want to focus all my
time and energy on my family and on my
tennis and you know when you do get
involved in
certain topics and subjects you know
attracts more more attention more
questions
more time you know more comments online
and that can be quite tiring as well yes
well i mean you mentioned your family
there of course as well as three
daughters and a son you've been very
influenced by strong women in your life
not least your mum the pro tennis coach
of course judy murray um and she
recently wrote an article and i i
actually i remember reading it when it
came out
and you know
it's it's a terribly shocking but
horribly familiar story to quite a lot
of women i have to say uh she she wrote
about being sexually assaulted at an
awards dinner by a man sat next to her
i just wondered did you know already
that story and and did she tell you she
was going to share it
my brother um was aware that i wasn't um
my mom did message me at the time to let
me know that there was an article coming
out
um about it
and yeah i was obviously really
upset for her um
you know i was
i was pretty angry but also didn't
i didn't know quite exactly what to say
um and obviously i you know i messaged
my mom i called her the following day to
talk to her to make sure that she was
okay and
yeah like you say it's obviously it's a
familiar story for for a lot of women
and um yeah that that sort of behavior
shouldn't shouldn't be tolerated
anywhere yeah i mean she also wrote as
part of this which is a big part of what
your mum has done
is you know women are made to feel the
world of sport is not for us and our
presence is neither welcome nor
important and what i mean by that is
your mum has done a lot of work to try
and change that you know to be a big
part of the world of sport she is um i i
wonder when you have thought about
sexism and how women are perceived
you've of course also had a female coach
yourself that was a big story at the
time even though it shouldn't have been
uh in many ways
how do you stop those men it's not all
men in sport of course but those men in
sport making women feel like your mum
described
that's a good question which i probably
don't
don't know all of the answers to i think
some of it probably comes from education
some of it probably comes from having
more
women around um so that it's not
something that it seems out of the norm
um
certainly
i
like you mentioned i got a taste of that
when i hired a female coach um and that
was very rare like on the men's tour and
the women's tour there's very few women
uh
coaches and
i didn't think much of it at the time
when i hired a female coach like
i'd never personally in my early
twenties thought about it because i'd
always seen all of the top players all
working with male coaches
i had a conversation with darren cahill
who's one of the the top australian
coaches and said well you know what
about speaking to some female coaches
and i was like yeah i mean
why not why wouldn't i do that
i then went down the route of employing
emily maresma who was a former world
number one wimbledon champion and
you know
even when there was rumors about me
potentially working with her the
comments that i was getting from
fellow players fellow coaches
was something i'd never experienced
before and that was when i realized that
there was was quite a big problem and i
think that until it becomes the norm
that there is
more than just
the odd one or two female coaches on the
tour of you know two or three hundred um
i think that that is probably always
going to be an issue but i mean
hopefully things are changing slowly yes
i mean
i suppose when we look at the world of
sport and i know i'm broadening this out
slightly but i know you will have seen
this that recently jake daniels became
the first active footballer to come out
as gay a lot of people have said that
was very brave because of football and
how football is perceived and how it is
to be a footballer when it comes to
being open about your sexuality i i
wonder when we talk about the world of
sport what was your reaction to that and
and
do you think it is getting better in
being more reflective of the wider
population and not not the world it
thinks it should present but the world
as it is um i do think it is getting a
bit better and i think that that was
really positive that he felt comfortable
enough to to come out and you know from
what i've seen most of the
um the the coverage um
you know has been extremely positive um
about it
um in the media
how
that will play out at football grounds
up and down the country that will be i i
guess a bigger test and hopefully it's
you know his experience is really
positive as well and
um but yeah you you would think that
you know
certainly in tennis there's been no
male tennis players um have come out as
gay whilst they've still been playing
so you would um
you know a few have come out uh post uh
post careers so
you know
we maybe have to ask the question as to
why that is the case and why you know
they still don't feel um comfortable um
to come out whilst they're still active
but i would hope that it would be
viewed positively by
all of the all of the players and that's
certainly been the case on on the female
side so i didn't actually know that
about male tennis players i hadn't
looked into
into that but that that's also
interesting i mean is it is it a
particularly behind the scenes i don't
know when you're on tour is it is there
a lot of bravado and having to be macho
and i say that in inverted commerce you
know sort of being one way do you think
that's what it's about the conformity
perhaps i haven't seen it
in terms of like
sexuality i think in um
in sport there is always
well certainly in male sport like you
know about being like a like tough and
being a real man and you know not
showing any emotions and those sorts of
things and
whether something like that would play a
part in it i've certainly found it
difficult times like earlier in my
career to
open up to the coaches and stuff that
were around me because
i don't know like showing emotions and
these sorts of things were you know
always seen as as kind of being a a
weakness um
you know so i've seen it in in that
sense but not you know in the locker
rooms around someone's sexuality yeah
but i mean you've also spoken a lot
about mental health and
how younger players in particular do
need more support
especially to try and be themselves when
they suddenly find themselves in the
spotlight
you mentioned their emotions and and how
you were early on in your career i did
spy just before we started to talk a
recent instagram post of you uh smiling
very broadly holding a cup of coffee
saying after years of being miserable
and incapable of smiling i wish i'd
known that all i needed was a coffee uh
is it is it fun owning that view that
some people had of you that you didn't
really seem that happy at first
well i wasn't i wasn't that happy and
in
i was happy in certain aspects but no i
i didn't feel comfortable in front of a
camera
you know my life changed um
you know almost overnight for the from
the first time i played in wimbledon um
as an 18 year old and got to the third
round and i wasn't ready for that i
wasn't prepared for that it's difficult
i think to prepare anyone um
you know to have that to sort of no one
in the streets knowing you and you know
you know just you just playing tennis
and playing in front of 10 15 people to
all of a sudden playing on
you know the center court wimbledon
you know with millions of people
watching on the tv and getting followed
by paparazzi back to your house and
those sorts of things and seeing your
face on papers and everything and you
know
comments and
things that you might have said to your
your friends that you've maybe made the
mistake of you know saying
in front of a camera you know all of a
sudden you're getting a
cent abuse people saying stuff to you up
in the streets and these sorts of things
and it was really difficult and not you
you know you then you would i think
naturally go into your shell and not
want to open up and just
you know put up a bit of a shield and
that's you know certainly what what i
did and
um you know was not that happy being in
front of a camera and did not feel
comfortable in it and i
i
you know it's my responsibility how i
deal with um
you know that that side of things but
um
yeah i don't think the media helped me
um through that period and i don't think
that probably enough is is done to help
young athletes prepare themselves for
um
the
the spotlight at such a young age i am
praying that you're going to win
wimbledon
thank you me too are you praying or are
you training about both i don't i i'm
i'm training i don't pray okay
i'm not sure i've put it quite into
prayer yeah but i am really hoping let's
put it like that and when you raw with
each fist pump i'll be i'll be thinking
of what you were saying about all of
this and it's a pleasure to talk to you
andy murray thank you so much thank you
very much and thank you for being with
us until next time stay safe
[Music]